die fernsehsendung für gründer und
erfinder die auf der suche nach
investoren sind hunderttausende von euro
sind über die letzten zehn staffeln
investiert worden aber was wird produkte
kommen am ende wirklich dabei um genau
dieser frage bin ich auf den grund
gegangen und habe sieben produkte in die
in der sendung investiert wurde für euch
getestet und unter die lupe genommen was
das für produkte sind ob sie ein halten
was sie versprechen und ob ich euch
empfehlen würde diese produkte zu kaufen
erfahrt ihr im video ich wünsche euch
viel spaß ich freue mich unglaublich auf
dieses video hölle der löwen nach einem
der einzigen serien für die ich den
fernseher in den letzten jahren noch
eingeschaltet habe und ich bin jetzt
sehr gespannt was am kunden dabei
herumgekommen ist ich habe das so
sortiert dass wir die produkte vom
kleinsten funding bis zum größten
aufbauen also ganz zum schluss kommt das
produkt ihnen das am meisten geld
investiert wurde und wo 50.000 euro pro
prozent anteil bezahlt wurden bestand
aber mit dem geringsten funding 30
prozent für 50.000 euro haben sie
angefragt im endeffekt haben sie genau
diese 30 für 50.000 von carsten
maschmeyer bekommt und das hier ist das
produkt ziemlich coole story hinter
diesen dingen zwei super junge leute so
weit ich weiß aus düsseldorf 17 und 18
und das hier ist alles was wir geschickt
bekommen haben das smart way to connect
im prinzip eine super einfache lösung
eine digitale visitenkarte wie viel das
wirklich taugt schauen wir uns jetzt
gemeinsam an das hier ist das
eigentliche produkt um das wir uns
kümmern von den gründern angedacht ist
dass man sich diesen chip irgendwohin
klebt wo er gut zu erreichen ist denn es
ist ein mir viel chip da drin
nahfeldkommunikation
das kennt ihr von eurer sparkassen karte
wenn ihr die beim bezahlen auflegt und
im prinzip ist es genauso nur dass hier
alle kontaktinformationen hinterlegt
werden das bedeutet man muss nicht
unmengen an papier verschwinden um
irgend welche visitenkarten zu drucken
sondern hat das immer digital dabei ich
habe allerdings ein paar bedenken wir
schauen uns das jetzt aber erstmal
ich habe mein profil eingerichtet das
hat gar nicht so lange gedauert wenn man
ihnen bei einer fremden person ans handy
hält sollte sich eigentlich eine website
öffnen und wir kommen auf meinem profil
das ding ist wenn ich nämlich jetzt
jemanden eine visitenkarte ausleihen
möchte meinen kontakt weitergeben möchte
kann ich ohne jede weitere kosten meinen
eigenen kontakt in meinem iphone
erstellen draufklicken unten auf kontakt
teilen drücken und per drop jemanden
suchen indem ich den kontakt
weiterleiten mit klar das funktioniert
mit android nicht aber ich weiß nicht ob
diese lösung wirklich 14 euro wert ist
carsten maschmeyer und die analysen
waren auch nicht besonders überzeugt
davon carsten maschmeyer wollte die
beiden gründern die jungen gründer aber
supporten darin die weite ihren kram
machen können und das finde ich mega
cool für mich ist es mittlerer daumen
der eher richtung unten geht weil es
kein wirkliches problem löst auf das ich
jemals gestoßen bin produkt zwei
vielleicht meine absolute lieblingsstadt
main ist etwas unglaubliches verspricht
text über ein aufsatz für eine
bierflasche die aus einer normalen
bierflasche quasi die kleinste
zapfanlage der welt machen so leute die
gerne bier trinken so wie auch ich kenne
das problem flaschen bier schmeckt
einfach nicht so wie ein frisch
gezapftes und genau hier soll der text
iro abhilfe schaffen wir fließt beim
einschenken durch spezielle sieb
struktur mehr sauerstoff kontakt großes
versprechen sie wollten 50.000 euro und
dafür 25 prozent ihrer firma abgeben das
haben sie von rolf deml bekommen für 14
euro 39 habe ich drei aufsätze bekommen
wenn es funktioniert ein super cooles
kleines geschenk was sich nice
mitbringen lässt und es eine coole party
spielereien wenn es denn funktioniert
und das schauen uns jetzt ab verpackung
ist schon mal
das hier ist der aufsatz für die
pet-flasche dass sie ist der aufsatz für
die glasflasche und wir werden jetzt im
blindtest
ich mag's kommst du einmal testen das
wiederhören du wirst jetzt hier von
einem schluck nehmen dann werde ich
wieder etwas einschränken müssen dann
musst du mir sagen ob der erste versuch
oder der zweite versuch besser schmeckt
okay vielleicht herr am frühen morgen
aber es schmeckt noch fit und
jetzt fest nummer zwei
geht an einen wirklichen unterschied
wahrzunehmen es riecht weniger her
irgendwie
kosten nicht besser was mich mehr nach
einem gezapften hier also das schmeckt
für mich deutlich besser das andere hat
hat sehr herb geschmeckt und dies hier
schmeckt so bisher hat so ein bisschen
mehr so eine vollkommen fitte und wir
zuschauer so eine cremige textur würde
ich fast sagen tatsächlich kamen das
zweite aus dem kleinsten zapfhahn der
welt und ich habe es gerade schon auch
einmal probiert weil ein bisschen welten
und es ist in welchen unterschied es ist
kein witz es ist genauso wie ich es mir
vorgestellt habe aber es ist wirklich
geisteskranken ja es war weniger
bitterstoffe drin sind unfähig und mit
ohne alles das schmeckt für mich
deutlich besser für mich auch ich hätte
nicht mal gewusst hast das gleiche wie
er ist und genau das ist in der sendung
auch passiert dafür dass die 25 prozent
für 50.000 euro abgegeben haben glaube
ich war es ein unheimlich schlechter
deal ich habe tatsächlich herausfinden
können 2020 kam eine news das 1,5
millionen stück davon verkauft wurden
und das absolut mit recht für mich ist
ein absolutes winner produkt die
prozente die abgegeben wurden meiner
meinung nach deutlich zu viel aber
absolutes top produkt in den text so
hätte ich sofort investieren wenn diese
möglichkeit dazu gehabt das problem ist
unwahrscheinlich viele von euch haben
nicht die möglichkeit frühzeitig in
startups investiert aber es gibt eine
möglichkeit in große bestehende und
gewinnbringende 64 hier kommt ein broker
sale becketts endspiel travel capital
ist nicht nur finanzfluss sechziger
sondern auch mein broker der wahl und
fester partner ihr können super easy
übers handy und eine desktop version in
aktien etf skripte und viele weitere
finanzprodukte investiert account
eröffnung ist super easy übers handy
möglich komplett kostenlos und ihr könnt
ab einem euro schon in aktien crypto und
etf-sparpläne investieren und mit einer
trading flatrate fallen die eh schon
geringen oder gebühren von 99 cent auch
noch weg wenn ihr also anfangen wollen
zu investieren einen neuen rocker sucht
oder euch vielleicht einfach mal mit app
vertraut machen wollt klickt auf den
ersten link in einer video beschreibung
und ladet euch scalable captain rund um
sich den einstieg aber ein bisschen zu
erleichtern bekommt gerade als neukunde
eine 20 euro prämie alle
teilnahmebedingungen und informationen
findet ihr und auch hier noch mal geht
das ganze langsam und im eigenen tempo
anzieht euch die finanzfluss videos rein
sammelt informationen und versteht das
thema bevor ihr geld investiert wenn er
aber geld investieren wollte kann es
sehr gut sein dass gable kapitel der
richtige bohrer für euch ist ist ein
deutsches unternehmen aus münchen die
deutsche bank aus münchen steht dahinter
und ich habe euch wie beim letzten mal
den finanzfluss broker vergleich auch
wieder in die video beschreibung gepackt
in dem scalable capital als testsieger
rausgegangen gegner auf den ersten link
checkers aus jetzt viel spaß weiter mit
dem lied also eine sache nicht vergessen
ein zuschauer hat für mich die website
dave - investitionen punkt.de gebaut da
könnt ihr übrigens meine über ein
komplettes 40 keiten was du trägst ist
megageil und da seht ihr wie mein
aktueller stand ist viel spaß wir
bleiben im getränkesektor das nächste
produkt heißt udo einen deckel für alle
tasten von einer kölner studentin die 20
für 100.000 euro wollte bekommen hat sie
100.000 euro aber für 33 prozent von
rolf deml und das produkt sieht
folgendermaßen aus die studentin steht
nachhaltiges design und dieses produkt
das in einer aufgabe entstanden einen
nachhaltigen kaffee to go becher zu
gestalten und so wird das ganze auch
vermarktet und möglicherweise wird ihm
das auch gleich in meiner bewertung zum
verhängnis im prinzip man nimmt eine
taste von zu hause seine lieblings taste
so wird vermarktet füllt sein wasser im
zweifelsfall eher sein café rein und
benutzt diesen deckel als wir erinnern
und to go lösung da passiert drauf wir
drücken ihnen fest habe ich tatsächlich
aber nur bedenken dass er wirklich dicht
ist es so dass ein to go becher nicht
dicht ist weil er oben kommt sätzlich
eröffnung hat diese öffnung hier lässt
sich aber zu schließen das bedeutet man
könnte erwarten dass das produkt ist
doch okay wenn man es darauf anlegt
kopflos raus aber an und für sich war es
in meinem falle jetzt dicht es ist ja
eher dafür gedacht das ist weil so ein
bisschen umfallen kann und es ist
zumindest nicht komplett ausgelaufen das
ist ganz gut aber was halte ich jetzt
eigentlich von diesem produkt ich glaube
dass die aufgabe eines to go becher oder
einer nachhaltigen lösung für eine tuba
ich hab gar nicht richtig gelöst wurde
weil wenn ich einen deckel für eine
bestehende tasse mit nehme dann habe ich
dieses to go ging nicht mehr ich kaufe
ein kaffee to go weil ich im stress bin
und schnellen kaffee trinken möchte und
dann greife ich nicht in meine
hosentasche und ziehe meine
lieblingstasse raus und hab dann auch
noch den deckel dabei to go ist das hier
nicht um seinen kaffee von zu hause mit
auf den weg zur arbeit zu nehmen im auto
und dienst verschließen ist es bestimmt
gut aber für einen preis von 10 euro 80
und eigentlich auch abseits des preises
halte ich dieses produkt zumindest in
meinem falle für wenig sinnvoll das gibt
für mich einen daumen nach unten es tut
mir leid udo also ganz kurz
zwischendurch alle links zu den
produkten sind in der video beschreibung
keiner feelings bei amazon mehr nach der
doppel sache meinen philipp account
komplett gestrichen hat und ich das geld
nach wie vor nicht bekommen habe liebe
grüße wir bleiben aber nachhaltigkeit
sektor blue green ist unser nächstes
produkt für 999 soll man hier 50 prozent
wasser sparen und gleich bleibenden du
spaß haben und anscheinend soll es
abseits der normalen wasser sparer
deutlich besser funktioniert 100 kay für
20 prozent haben sie angefragt 111 für
30 prozent haben sie wieder einmal von
rolf deml bekommen und so sieht das
ganze aus super einfach zu nutzen man
schraubt das ganze einfach zwischen
seine durch vorrichtung und den
duschschlauch und das hier ist das ganze
produkt cool klein fühlt sich wertig an
und das ganze funktioniert
folgendermaßen in diesem kleinen teil
fließt das wasser durch eine verjüngung
dabei entsteht deutlich mehr druck als
eigentlich auf dem wasser ist durch
unterdruck wird dann noch wasser
hinzugefügt und der gründer vergleich
etwas mit mousse au chocolat dass so ein
bisschen aufgeht und fluffig wird und so
scheint es auch mit diesem ding und
wasser zu sein das produkt kostet gerade
einmal 99 90 bei einer vierköpfigen
familie wäre das eine wassereinsparung
bei 50 prozent von 250 euro wasserkosten
in meinem falle einer zweiköpfigen eg
während also 125 euro und das produkt
hätte sich mit 10 auf einkaufspreis nach
gerade einmal 25 41 tagen amortisiert
wenn du spaß also gleich bleiben sollte
und sich das gefühl dabei nicht ändert
ist das für mich auch ein absolutes
winning produkt und deswegen habe ich
das die letzten tage getestet
also das produkt super verarbeitet ist
sieht super gut aus ist mega kleines
lied passt auf ihre dusche zehn euro ist
ein cooler preis das problem an der
sache ist der du [ __ ] bleibt nicht
gleich zumindest in meinem fall laut
hersteller hängt es ein bisschen davon
ab wie weit man vom wasserwerk entfernt
ist und wie gut der allgemeine druck in
der dusche ist bei uns scheint es
einfach nicht das richtige zu sein wenn
man allerdings auf kompletter sparflamme
leben will funktioniert dieses produkt
definitiv deswegen ist für mich ein
mittelding cool aber nicht ganz das was
verspricht und irgendwer nicht mehr erst
auf das nächste produkt bin ich wirklich
sehr gespannt denn es könnte ein problem
ein großes problem von mir endlich lösen
das nennt sich schlug ist bzw zum
zeitpunkt der ausstrahlung der sendung
hieß es noch focus es ist ein koffein
wasser dann löst dieses produkt jetzt
aber ein problem von bevor wir zu dieser
antwort kommen sie wollten 100 kg und
dafür 25 prozent abgeben haben hunderte
bekommen 25 prozent abgegeben und dazu
noch 500.000 euro für außenwerbung
bekommen in einer investoren kombination
aus drei engel und carsten maschmeyer
stimme ist wieder am start investiert
wenn alles perfekt null kalorien auf 100
milliliter 0 gramm zucker ist wasser mit
etwas zitronengeschmack jetzt kommen wir
zu meinem problem ich habe ein riesiges
smarte problem ich liebe koffein ich
trinke am tag tatsächlich so circa 2
liter mate was so viel koffein und so
viel zucker ist und ich möchte dass es
aufhört denn ich merke dass mir
tatsächlich schlecht geht aber ich würde
fast sagen dass ich eine sucht
entwickelt haben und das ist kein witz
hier bitte kurz im bild von unserem
handwerk einblenden es ist tatsächlich
nicht mehr witzig dass hier hat im
prinzip alles was ich suche koffein
wenig kalorien beziehungsweise keine und
keinen zucker und kostet 1 euro 66 pro
flasche und damit 3 euro 33 pro liter
jetzt kommen wir aber zum geschmack zum
wichtigsten und dazu ob es mir ich habe
extra keine mate getrunken werde jetzt
die nächsten tage probieren auf dieses
wasser umzusteigen
mit kohlensäure und es schmeckt
vertraut blog ist
also geschmacklich ist das so wie die
talks maßnahmen nicht so also
tatsächlich mit 20 milligramm auf 100
milliliter ist es genau das von dort so
marte nur hat machte fünf gramm zucker
das bedeutet bei einem halben liter
zieht man sich 25 gramm zucker rein und
das dürfte das sind nein ich auch nicht
alle gestimmt ich denke auch ich werde
das in den nächsten tagen weiter im auge
behalten und das ist meine finale
bewertung das antwort genug so viel ist
noch kein flug ist richtig dass konkrete
büro ist quasi von anderen
koffeinhaltigen getränken jetzt
zumindest daraus da ist hier auch
umgestiegen es funktioniert ist schmeckt
ist megageil ob ich nochmal bestelle ich
wage es zu bezweifeln weil ich es nicht
einfach so entweder oder so kaufen kann
aber so produktes geld produkt nummer
sechs bin ich sehr gespannt drauf ich
habe vorher schon davon gehört dass
heißt das puder clip zum zeitpunkt der
ausstrahlung hieß es noch aspera clip
sie wollten 600.000 euro unter 14
prozent abgeben bekommen haben sie ein
deal der insgesamt eine million euro
umfasst und haben dafür 25 prozent
abgegeben davon 600.000 euro cash rein
und 400.000 euro working capital was ist
genau bedeutet ich habe keine ahnung so
sieht die verpackung aus pro packung
sind jeweils zwei clips und eine treppe
beck dabei da kann man den clip dann
rein tun denn er ist tatsächlich
mehrfach zu verwenden das ding ist ich
habe mir tatsächlich extra alle
sendungen dafür angeschaut und was
diesem produkt ganz besonders macht ist
dass sie ein patent darauf haben ein
mini miniaturisiertes inhalationsgerät
für die nase zu haben und es gilt als
medizinisches produkt galt ist zumindest
zum zeitpunkt der ausstrahlung diese
medizinische zulassung wurde ihnen
langfristig dann leider wieder
weggenommen die gründe haben super viele
business möglichkeiten in ihrem pitch
erzählt beispielsweise dass sie durch
die medizinische zulassung die
möglichkeit haben
hier medikamente in diese beiden
katholischen rhein zu tun und dann quasi
nasal medikamente zuzuführen und auch
jetzt schon ohne das medikament hier
drin sind nur mit ätherischen ölen die
in diesen beiden kartuschen sind soll es
entzündungshemmend wirken und sie haben
so ein bisschen damit verglichen mit
dieser standard haushalts methode wo man
topf mit heißem wasser ätherischen ölen
und handtuch drüber quasi in seiner
hosentasche mitführen kann einer der
leute die bei uns mit im büro sitzen
kennt das benutzt das tatsächlich selber
bei erkältung ich habe es die letzten
tage auch schon getestet und was soll
ich sagen ich bin mega überzeugt meine
nase ist grundsätzlich so ein bisschen
zu also
ist grundsätzlich ein bisschen zu und
ich habe das ding gestern den ganzen tag
drin gehabt und unheimlich gut atmen
könnte man sieht natürlich auch ein
bisschen komisch aus wenn man dieses
ding die ganze zeit in der nase hat
aber man atmet frei und die atemwege
werden frei und es funktioniert zwei
euro 49 pro stück kostet das oder im
bundle ich habe sechs stück auf einmal
bestellt da habe ich 14 99 bezahlt ist
dieses produkt aber ein must-have weiß
ich nicht schauen aber mal wie es
aussieht wenn ich das nächste mal eine
erkältung habe für mich ist es so ein
produkt irgendwie geil aber ohne
medizinische zulassung er so und damit
kommen wir zu meinem finalen sind ein
produkt das mit abstand am meisten
investitionen ab sand hat smart nennt
sich das ganze von dr lorac einem schlaf
forscher über 14 jahre hinweg entwickelt
haben wollte er 250.000 14 was bedeutet
er hatte zum zeitpunkt der ausschreibung
seien viermal mit zweieinhalb millionen
euro bewertet zu diesem deal ist es
nicht gekommen er hat aber angebote von
allen lösen bekommen und hat sie im
endeffekt für 31 prozent der für 1,5
millionen euro mit carsten maschmeyer
und drive to manage wer auch sonst mit
diesem 1,5 millionen euro deal ist es
das mit abstand am höchsten finanzierte
produkt jemals bei höhle der löwen und
ich bin extrem gespannt dieses produkt
verspricht nicht schneller einschlafen
zu können besser einschlafen zu können
sondern vielmehr mehrere generationen in
der schlafphase zu erzeugen für mich
tatsächlich eine unheimlich geniale idee
denn ich komme häufig nicht dazu sieben
bis acht stunden zu schlafen im prinzip
sind zwei komponenten inhaltsstoffe sind
aminosäuren kreativen und vitamine was
genau keine ahnung steht bestimmt hinten
drauf aber jupp kein wir hoffen dass es
funktioniert
zwei tabletten eingenommen werden sollen
danach soll das man dieser flüssig
herunter gespühlt werden leo hat gerade
richtigerweise gesagt es ist so ein
bisschen will klickt ich werde in den
nächsten sieben tagen voraussichtlich
tatsächlich ein wenig schlaf kommen weil
wir viel produzieren müssen und so
deswegen ist das hier scheinbar das
wundermittel was mir unter die arme
greift und das hier ist mein fazit
in fresh ich bin frecher als normal
smart sleep funktioniert kein witz ich
bin heute morgen aufgestanden und hab
mich unendlich gut gefühlt ich habs
jetzt vier tage hintereinander genommen
vier tage an denen nicht weniger
geschlafen habe als ich eigentlich hätte
schlafen sollen das produkt hat mich
definitiv überzeugt die frage ist das
ist eigentlich nicht der weg das
schlafen oder schlafprobleme oder zu
kurze schlafen anzugreifen man muss sich
einfach die zeit nehmen länger zu
schlafen wenn das mal nicht funktioniert
smarsly gute option langfristig nicht
der beste weg das war es also mit der
ersten folge von ich habe höhe der löwen
produkte unter die lupe genommen wenn
ich das gefallen hat was wir gerne live
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
dann sehen wir uns am sonntag schon
wieder ich liebe es einfach nicht rein
zu schauen zu gucken welche produkte
warum gut warum schlecht sind und diese
hier für euch zu testen wenn ihr mehr
dieser videos sehen wollt vergesst nicht
mich dass in den kommentaren wissen zu
lassen es gibt über zehn staffeln also
eine menge produkte es gibt noch stark
aus amerika wir haben eine menge zu
testen macht es gut ist dahin